[Music]
this is so awesome um this is so awesome
i just watched the movie this morning
and one i loved it two i'm sure you've
heard that a lot today two the number
one thing that you know everybody from
imax i think wants to know
is we've never actually seen an imax
camera in front of the camera before
how did that come about and or why did
that come that's right there's an imax
camera is a
essentially a character in the film or a
prop and an important prop
an essential prop so i worked with hoyt
of hoitama in this film and i knew i
wanted to create an absolute spectacle
something
bigger
ambitious
uh more undeniable than i'd ever done
and so i knew hoyt was the man and uh
one of the first things i asked him was
hoyt if forget the movies
if you had to
get an image of a ufo in the sky you had
one shot and it was for posterity
um for huma the human race what would
you do what would you use and he goes in
his
classic dutch accent jordan i would use
an imax camera
and it is because the resolution is just
on a whole different level
that is the way to go so i was like cool
and so
we shot you know about 35 of the film
um
the spectacle part and uh uh
in imax and the characters in the film
use an imax to capture the ufo so it's a
total meta thing
and it's just a it's a great way to do
my first imax film
i it was awesome i got to tell you the
imax folks we were all like let's go
we were very excited
um talking about hoyta um
how did he come about in the process um
you know definitely he's worked with
christopher nolan before on you know
imax films in the past
what what kind of led you to bring him
on and how did that
add to the film well and you know the
the the work he's done with nolan is
truly
inspiring and talk about um absolute
spectacles right we've got interstellar
we've got dunkirk we've got tenet you
know three um movies that i've i've seen
in imax and they're they really push the
the the boundaries of what is done i
mean yeah he's he he was i knew i wanted
scope and i knew i wanted scale so he
was kind of the only guy and i think
like the
i would say the world's foremost uh imax
cinematographer so i had to get them you
balance the the spectacle with intimate
moments in this film as well like i
think you
found a great way to really bring the
tension through both of those
like talk about balancing that as a
filmmaker and
just what that process looked like for
you well
you know we came in to
the film and
you know one you know wanting to use the
imax for the the scope of it all
and and the scale and the spectacle what
i found along the way
is that there's all sorts of other
ground that hasn't been broken with this
format with this type of camera and that
yes in fact
the more
some of the more intimate some of the
more regular environments
it created an experience that i i hadn't
even expected in terms of the um the
immersion
the teleportation and and in terms of
the horror i was able to get some
intimate horror moments in in that imax
format
that uh is unlike anything that exists
and i think that's that's so cool and it
really works you know it's rare that
people film with actual film these days
um could you talk about you know that
process and how it may be different from
working on some of your past films
well
you know i i
it felt
like
a
a movie that absolutely needed to be
shot in film
i i i felt like i
it was begging to be it was about film
and
and it was about the
in in many ways it's about the first
film and it's a sort of sequel to that
first film
um
there's something
uh about uh capturing magic and and um
and putting it in a box and and putting
tangible confines around it that's
intrinsic to the filmmaking process
and the way i'm exploring the spectacle
in here is the is the the wonder and
beauty and awe of spectacle but also
the human need to an addiction to it
i want to talk a little bit about the
sound design because i mean you know
bruce marco i've talked with bruce in
the past and he told me kind of off the
cuff that the sound design this movie is
like
some of the best he's ever heard
and and you know like
award level like he was just gushing
over it so when i saw it this morning i
saw exactly what he meant
um could you talk about you know the
sound and and kind of how that
contributes to the immersion and
heightened sense of tension throughout
the film well bruce is awesome and and i
and i trust him because i know he used
to be a sound guy
and uh it's true i've got a
johnny byrne who and his team in in
london are
truly incredible they did under the skin
which is one of my favorite movies and
uh he created a scout a soundscape that
really uh is totally immersive
so
you know when say when you're in the an
imax uh environment for example um
you really do have a system that's
everywhere and you have this this
feeling of being
in and underneath
this kind of this tapestry he's created
so i'm so glad you liked it we we really
wanted to um
we really wanted to not only give you
the the sound the sound of ufo but the
sound of the world
um as affected by the presence of a ufo
i think that came across very well
more of a general question you jordan
peele if you could experience any film
in imax for the first time or again wow
what would it be what a great question
if i tell you this you got to make it
happen for me right yeah we'll make it's
going to happen okay any movie for the
first time or again can be anything
let's just say theoretically just open
it up oh my gosh well let's get crazy
alien
i mean come on yes come on i just think
that would be insane it shares some of
the the dna of this project i guess in
that it's uh
it's it's
juxtaposition of the the
the horror of the vastness
and the horror of the intimate space
and um so yeah i think i i would love to
see that in a double feature with no oh
my god i actually that makes so much
sense i could see that too that's really
sick
um i love that choice i would maybe go
terminator 2.
just
that's another one right throw it back
so good man
five stars angel five stars you know
imax is really the the best way to see
this film just because you know
i i think i wanted an experience where
the audience really if they're looking
up they really have to look up
they have to feel what the characters
feel
and uh you know with imax it's not you
know you're not just watching a movie
you're existing in a place it's kind of
how it feels